Hey Team it’s Charlie and this week for
my bonus video I wanted to do an update on
this year’s Christmas Special and my favorite
guest characters from all the specials.
They just announced most if not all of this
years big guest stars and it’s a pretty
exciting group.
The giveaway is still running till I post
my Q&A tomorrow, I’ll explain again at the
end of the video in case you have absolutely
no idea what I’m talking about.
Starting off with Christmas Special Updates:
They just officially announced these people
will guest star Nick Frost of Cornetto Fame,
Patrick Troughton the second doctor’s son,
Nathan McMullen from Misfits, Natalie Gumede
from Coronation Street and Faye Marsay from
Glue.
Nick Frost was seen earlier this week walking
around the set with Dan Starkey who plays
Strax.
They’ve been filming the special at St Mellons
Golf Club and Vaendre Hall in Cardiff.
Here’s a couple pictures of the manor they’ve
been filming around.
Now that they’ve confirmed Frost it also
sounds like the Paternoster Gang or at least
Strax will be in the special.
Which explains why they’re filming near
a victorian looking manor.
They might be back in Victorian times.
No word on who Nick Frost is playing but the
best rumor I’ve seen is that it’s Santa
Claus or someone in a very santa like suit.
It is Christmas after all so there might be
some truth to that.
I feel like now that two thirds of the Cornetto
gang have been on Doctor Who, Edgar Wright
will have to cave and direct an episode soon.
Wouldn’t it be crazy if they got all three
of them together for the same episode.
It would totally kill Doctor Who’s budget,
but it’s fun to imagine.
Edgar Wright actually said that Russell T.
Davies offered him the job of directing the
2005 debut of series 1 Rose.
But he had to turn it down because he was
working on Shawn of The Dead.
He said his mother still hasn’t forgiven
him.
No idea yet who Patrick Troughton or any of
the other guest cast are playing or what the
story is going to be.
There’s really two ways it could go, it
could be a straight one-off like the 2011
christmas special, the Doctor, the Widow and
the Wardrobe.
Or it could deal with the aftermath of the
series 8 finale.
Right now with all the rumors going around
about Jenna Coleman leaving, I’m thinking
it will be the second option.
And be a bookend to the Missy storyline, the
doctor’s face and explaining how they’ll
proceed into series 9 next year.
With all the teasers about Clara having problems
trying to live a normal life and be a companion
I’m starting to think she will be moving
on.
But here’s a big question, look at some
of what’s happening in the teaser for episode
6 and tell me.
Does this look like the face of a companion
that’s going to stay or does it look like
Clara wants to have a go at being normal.
I’m still crying about the way Amy and Rory
left, so if Clara really does leave I can
only imagine how it will go down.
With the Christmas Special In Mind, here’s
my Top 5 Guest Actors to star a Special, just
Christmas Specials.
Number 5 - Lindsay Duncan in Waters of Mars
Of all the female guest stars during the David
Tennant Specials she felt like the most badass.
And how cool was it that she showed up in
Sherlock Series 3 last year?
I’m mostly just talking about the actors
themselves here, but I liked her character
adelaide brooks the most out of the temporary
companions.
Definitely the smartest and she was one of
the few female companions that didn’t automatically
start fawning over the doctor.
To be fair, they were being hunted down systematically,
so no much time for romance on Mars.
Number 4 - Richard E Grant in The Snowmen
He’s one of the few actors I could legitimately
be afraid of without having to put on a lot
of prosthetics or voice manipulation like
with Nicholas Briggs doing Dalek voice.
There are a lot of things you could say about
the series since Moffat took over as showrunner,
but I feel like he really pushed for the celebrity
guest stars in the specials.
Much more so than Russell Davies.
Unless you count Kylie Minogue and Timothy
Dalton.
Grant made Doctor Simeon feel like a real
threat to the Doctor without being too crazy
or over the top.
I don’t know that we’ll ever get to see
him on the series again just because of what
they did with his character.
As of the Series 7 finale he had become the
great intelligence, and I don’t know when
we’ll see that character again.
Number 3 - Ian McKellen also in The Snowmen
I went a little bit nuts when I heard he was
playing a character, it made a little more
sense when I found out it was just providing
some voice over until Richard E Grant took
on the Great Intelligence Persona.
But the way he made that giant snow globe
scary was so amazing.
He’s gandalf after all, you shall not pass
without being blown away.
Wouldn’t it be crazy if he did a brief walk
on cameo in a future special.
It would lead to all kinds of Great Intelligence
paradox theories.
Number 2 - Timothy Dalton in The End of Time
I think of all the big A list guest actors
and the characters they played he’s one
of my favorite on both counts.
There were some really cool guest actors like
David Morrisey who played really strange characters.
Usually when they cast big people they give
them really big roles.
But sometimes it just doesn’t work out the
way you want.
It was like watching Shakespeare Doctor Who
in the best possible way.
Dalton got to be the most infamous person
in the history of the canon next to The Omega
and The Master maybe and I feel like Russell
Davies just told him to go to town.
When someone that good comes in usually directors
will give them notes on what they want or
help them stay on story, but what you get
from them is so amazing.
They don’t need a lot of direction.
You just sit and watch them melt your face
off with their monologues.
His big cheer at the end of the first part
of End of Time is still one of my favorite
doctor who speeches ever.
To the End of Time Itself.
and my Number 1 favorite guest star on the
specials - Michael Gambon in A Christmas Carol
How awesome was it that Dumbledore agreed
to come on Doctor Who.
I feel like for every big actor that we see,
10 turned the series down for whatever reason.
But I feel like I don’t even need to say
too much about him as an actor.
He’s one of the greatest living actors in
the world right now add to that, he also just
happens to live in the UK which makes it a
little easier to get to Cardiff to film Doctor
Who.
There are a lot of amazing international actors
from everywhere but because of the way a lot
of British actors are brought up through the
theater, they have a distinct advantage in
genre shows like Doctor Who.
Just as a personal preference I like Science
Fiction and Fantasy to be a little more theatrical.
Even when it’s super depressing like Battlestar
it should still feel as up close and in your
face as a stage play.
That’s why some of the best moments from
Doctor Who so far have been Capaldi just talking
to himself.
Because he can just carry a scene without
big explosions or special effects.
And that requires a very special type of actor
that you don’t always find in America for
example.
That’s one of the reasons I’m totally
fine with all the future doctor’s being
British, be the male or female.
But now it’s your turn, let me know who
your favorite big guest actor has been in
all the specials.
I suppose you could bend the rules and include
anyone from any kind of special, not just
the christmas episodes.
The Q&A will post tomorrow, if you want to
enter the giveaway all you have to do is be
a subscriber and leave a comment.
Generally giveaways are only for the team.
So if you like to talk about Doctor Who, science
fiction or fantasy whatnot please join us.
Because I stayed up way too late last night
working on my Constantine video I was hallucinating
a little during Time Heist today.
To that effect here are a couple quick corrections
from my review.
When I was talking about the architect, I
was thinking about the person who designed
the bank, not the architect of the plan to
rob said bank.
Which was the doctor.
And in regards to the next episode.
Yes the doctor is the caretaker.
Because American and British terms for schools
are different I was thinking Caretaker meant
Principal, which in the UK would be Headmaster.
In America, the Caretaker of a school is called
the Janitor.
I didn’t think the Doctor would be a janitor,
which is why I said headmaster.
It’s just a wonky language thing.
I’ll try to post the Q&A early afternoon
pacific time.
You can click here to get it.
I’ll add the annotation as soon as I post
it and you can check out my time heist review
right here.
Thanks for watching, everybody high five quick
before I collapse from exhaustion.